well let's take a look at the process
are we okay and see how it would work we
can use a dizzee rascal as an example
and here's a couple of his back so the
record label that creates the videos and
owns the rights have to agree to submit
videos to the rating process and free
major-label so Sony universal and Warner
have signed up to that so those videos
are then sent to the British Board of
Film classification which will give the
video a rating so this video was rated
eighteen and only then will the videos
we uploaded to viewing sites as such as
YouTube and VEVO with a parental
advisory warning attached so that's the
process you sounded skeptical before do
you think this will work
I mean I know that I think your next
slide shows the statistics I mean this
is such a small fraction of all YouTube
and video content YouTube have a
mind-boggling is 65,000 videos a day get
loaded onto YouTube it's 300 hours a
minute can you imagine trying to police
all that content I know the people at
the BBFC are very busy very hard-working
but that would take a stadium full of
people I mean sort of just ants on a
hamster wheel they're chasing something
they cannot police I'm very concerned
about it well you mentioned the number
so let's take a look at numbers then
shall we because 132 music videos have
been submitted to the BBFC by labels
since this pilot began in October 132 of
them let's pour down into those a little
bit more because 56 have been rated as a
12 53 as a 15 only one classified as an
18 that was actually dizzy Russell's at
one that we've talked about before
however when you compare that with a
total number of videos released overall
in the same time over for a thousand of
them it's clear that a lot needs to be
done so as you say more labels need to
be encouraged to sign up but it's that
one I guess absolutely but on the other
hand the ones that do the likes that is
us but that's now become a forbidden
fruit I didn't know about this video
until it became an 18 certificate and
we've seen throughout history the the
songs that are banned the videos that
get boycotted on radio one off top of
the pops these are the songs that go to
number one all they do is become a
treasure chest but any curious teenager
every we've been teenagers that's what
you go after
and that's that the 18 he's become the
the golden so that's right and you say
looking back at history let's look back
a history a little bit because it isn't
just modern-day worries about sexuality
if you look at some of these examples
from the 80s and the 90s they've been
other concerns as well we maybe take
Madonna's like a prayer for example that
was controversial for different reasons
it was I mean this was have painting a
black Jesus who became her lover in the
video which of course was Madonna we
look back now it's just Madonna being
Madonna and it seems relatively tame but
you go back further in history I mean
people weren't shooting Elvis below the
waist in the 1950s so I mean I always
worry about censorship it's so
subjective in terms of we get some very
immature 40 year olds and we get some
very mature to under 12 year olds okay
darling we must leave it there thanks
very much thank you